[Music]
is it delicious lettuce I am gonna make
a salad out of endive Wow this is still
going the episode is brought to you by
the skin it's not brought to you our
diners drive-ins and dives the skin guys
it's a free newsletter sent to you every
single yeah it's free sent to you every
single morning with all the top news
stories compacted into a nice little
beautiful bite-sized email for you to go
learn and then learn your coworkers go
to the skim that's th es ki mmm comm
slash annejulien when you sign up you'll
be entered and a shot to where the $250
Visa gift card and you get information
for free okay and it's it's great bite
size wonderful stuff also brought to you
by texture guys you want to read some
magazines yeah but you don't want to do
it in a clunky yeah old fashioned way
yeah then you get texture texture is an
app right now that you can start for
free with the trial and you go to
texture comm slash annejulien
guys if you choose to continue after
your trial and you'll get texture for
just $9.99 s $9.99 a month over 30% of
their listed price is off 30% off of
their lesser price just for the dink
yeah okay
no thanks for watching delicious
[Music]
[Music]
what diners drive-ins it dive
sister Jenna what have we been up to oh
we trying to buy a house well we're
starting the process
yeah we're saying the process it's
stressful as a [ __ ] yeah I mean
we're not in any hurry you guys know
that we although our house is very
frustrating because we rent so like the
toilet sometimes don't always work here
it's very frustrating but like we do
love our location and we love our our
space in a podcast room in our office
and you know our nice living room and
our dogs have fun here it's fun place so
we're looking for a really nice house
that we can live in and have some
working plumbing but it's gonna take a
while but we've been trying doing some
real adult - [ __ ] really don't - don't -
[ __ ] really don't really though we
looked at a place that had a well in the
backyard oh my god it was like concrete
concreted shut like it's like there was
a well it was it was there was nothing
else could have been it was a hundred
percent definitely a well at one point
and we looked at it and the top of it is
like you know concrete all the way
through so yeah but a ghost can still
get through cement you ain't fooling
nobody yeah and then there was like an
exotic animal cage next door yeah that's
crazy but anyways that's what we've been
up to but don't worry we're not gonna
like move or you know anything anytime
soon so we'll be here yeah and we'll
obviously keep you posted on stuff but
because we talk to you all the goddamn
time about everything Jenna's been
saying endive so back to that whole
thing we have an idea that we wanted to
do were oh you're talking last night
while we were drinking cuz it was
Colin's birthday so he'd gone out for
Colin's birthday waffle and we'd had I
did a couple of glasses of Pinot Grigio
and you know you come like some people
like smoke weed and get good ideas I
don't really smoke weed and ever but
like I get really good ideas like what
I'm drinking and they think they're
really good then you wake up the next
day and you're like that's [ __ ] dumb
man it's a dumb idea so we we had had a
couple of drinks and we were back at the
house eating some quesadillas and we
were like throwing around this really
funny idea for like a YouTube bread show
and because I like you to read I like a
lot of their original series like some
of them are really good but if you like
the air towards like scripted stuff and
I'm like why don't we have more like
good YouTube reality trash TV like sick
trash TV you know yeah the ones that we
like to watch on TV why don't we have
more of yes you know and like I think
people have tried it in the past but
like a little too serious like they're
not trash enough you know well that's
the problem it's like they're trying to
make YouTube a lot of the shows feel
like they're trying to make YouTube
similar to TV in the sense that it's
taken seriously and how they're doing it
so it's a little exactly yeah it's a
battle that you you don't just want to
make a reality show that exists on
YouTube and then people are like wow
that's that's garbage because it's a
youtubers show yeah a lot of them try
hard to make good reality sort of shows
the good thing about like I watch like
mr. Kato where they go around and
decorate and you know their interior
decorators and stuff like that like if
they made their show super trashy like
reality TV like it's almost so
self-aware that it's like hysterical
yeah
like that's you don't know you know you
don't want that like that's that doesn't
help anybody but like we were drinking
and we came up with this idea because we
were just watching bachelor Winter Games
which is fantastic brilliant
and we were like why don't we have like
a bachelor and bachelorette for
youtubers so like we came up with
a couple of you to read show ideas that
I just think Borgess these exist in the
not gonna exist but like let's throw out
some ideas
dear YouTube we know you're watching
please listen to our ideas and pay us
money for them and make them happy
nobody thank you to all the YouTube
executives who are sitting in the back
watching us right now I know you're here
I see you thank you for showing up we do
not validate parking YouTube I know
there's not a lot of seats some of you
are standing we get it just listen to
our pitch and you're gonna have content
for 2018 and on okay so Lance you're
welcome we came up because we were
sitting there with Brett we're like
giggling about it we're laughing really
hard like the idea of a bachelor or
bachelorette for youtubers so not
everyone is a youtuber you just pick the
bachelor or the Bachelorette aren't
there the youtuber yeah so the names
that I toss out were like Tyler Oakley
could be the bachelor out-of-season
Andrea Russett I feel like would be a
wonderful [ __ ] that would be
entertaining amazing yeah because she
keeps it real Trisha Paytas but we could
never never afford teas today that she's
gonna do a week-long livestream and if
that happens I'm doing nothing but
watching that for a week in fact I might
even just lie to myself watching it live
stream My Week live and I'm just like
pirating her okay so those are three but
it's important to understand the way it
would work is the main baths or
bachelorette would be a youtuber mm-hmm
we would go through the traditional
casting method of getting the rest of
the contestants to be like entertaining
and great yeah be from anywhere in the
country on TV
legally they probably have to be United
States citizens or a Canadian well
they're doing winter winter bachelor
games they're all international so you
know this is like that's far far no but
see I see all of you and I know you
you're just still filtering in I know
you guys have the budget to make things
like that happen so we're only cheating
for the stars here because we know what
capable of and we know the resources you
want to swing for the fences it's
important that we have some of the
contestants not know what YouTube is or
youtuber is we have this spectrum right
of incredibly thirsty fanboy fangirl and
then we have what's YouTube right and
they're all in the same house yeah and
the bachelor has to create content while
they're in the house they have to rock
why because half of the show is from the
camera crew and half of it is from the
vlog that's how you it's mixed in okay
well so my original sort of like wow so
my original sort of like I mean I I
watch The Bachelor in The Bachelorette
but like sometimes I skip seasons like
I'm not a die-hard fan but like some of
the seasons when you watch them because
it's like this crafted reality show
which I feel like a lot of you know
Millennials and younger people deviate
from like we don't we don't like when it
feels fake and forced and part of the
criticism of like The Bachelor is like
for any normal person if you wind up you
know thirty people for them to
potentially date and just by like
shaking hands and saying hello physical
attraction or you know just getting to
know a little bit about them you could
probably narrow that down to like
relatively you know ten or something we
are like I'd be interested in getting to
know that person a little bit more yeah
and then even after the end of like the
night or two days you could narrow it
down to like three people that you're
but no the entire season is like you
just keep all these people that you know
this person is clearly not really that
interested in yeah - no yeah for so long
it's like if you went to like middle
school again strong the [ __ ] out if
you're in high school and you even if
you don't have classes with everyone you
don't know everyone there's like a
couple of girls that you'd be into like
maybe asking to a dance or something you
know what I mean it's not like you're
interested in you're married for years
to figure out down to one yeah you need
to get to know all but that's that's
that's why the bachelor in practice is
so stupid right so that's why I was like
you know what I would really like
because I do like and I do think there
are a lot of people that are honestly
like looking genuinely looking for
someone to date I think the premise is
complete
ridiculous that everyone that goes on
those shows is even interested in the
bachelor or the Bachelorette whoever it
is like if you cast me on that show and
they're like it's Ari and you're like I
don't really like him
you know he's I don't he's not for me
but you can't do that as a contestant
you have to be like pretending like
you're completely in love with the
person which just is statistically not
really that believable but also one
thing that I I when I first watched The
Bachelor I was very confused by
everyone's interest in The Bachelor I
never understood but like it's it seems
apparent to everyone who's afraid of the
show it's like of course they want dad
or they want whatever Ari but when I
watch the per the first time I was like
well why are they so why are they all so
in love with this guy or girl I don't I
just didn't understand that alone that
question that when you first watch the
show at least for me it's like okay what
are the arteria motives here's a whole
list of them right right there's no way
this group of beautiful women are just
like diehard for a random human being
who is thrown in front of them and with
cameras like that's not right like the
idea spawned from like I would like to
watch a realistic bachelor or
bachelorette where anyone's allowed to
say I'm not interested I'm gonna leave
and the person is allowed to narrow down
and eliminate as the many people as they
why the way everyone the YouTube team we
are pitching basically just The Bachelor
today we have a couple other ideas but
we're doing best idea first so don't
stay till the end so say for example we
have a 7 million dollar budget and we
can afford treasure pages so like we
could say to her you know what's your
type or whatever you want and she could
probably look in a group of 30 guys and
be like I'm probably not that interested
in in this group and I'm very sorry but
I'm gonna have to eliminate you
I would rather ya watch like four or
five episodes of Trisha getting to know
like ten people on a better level than
pretending to like twenty five people so
in a way we're creating bachelor to
point out what we think would make the
best or so much better allistic but it's
gonna those guys if they if they look at
the contestant and they're just like you
know not for me or like I got to know
we're really not that interested like
feel free to leave you know does
because the premise is that they try to
sell you this like romantic love story
and have it build out but like I think
people are cool with watching other
people fall in love like we want it we
want to believe of course and it's
interesting to watch people date and see
the decision-making process about what
they decide they like about each other
or not if you made it a little more
realistic I think it would still be
entertaining especially if you allowed
people to be completely honest well I
think making it more realistic would
appeal not only to people who might feel
exactly how do you do about the show but
also like a younger more in touch
Internet crowd right like I want to see
what dating is really like I don't want
to watch them go on fancy dates and get
to know people they don't really care
about yeah and I don't want to see
people in a house for however many
months not have access to the Internet I
want to see him joke about memes like
that's what I do right like every
cutaway that they show of the people
waiting around the house it's only when
they're like pretty done up and makeup
and they're having a serious
conversation about how they all feel
about the bachelor it's like no show me
when they get drunk and run out of
toilet paper and four of them decide
that they're gonna create an alliance
against some other person Wow one of
them is Instagram live in yourself like
please like show me the people that are
there to get free booze and food for a
week and are partying and like like I'm
here for it yeah don't care I want to
see the weird [ __ ] yeah I want to see
someone falling down every week during
the episode so this is all is it live is
it like in the moment or is it recorded
like you because that's that's a
dictator the other like Shane Dawson is
always tossed around the idea of
Celebrity Big Brother for youtubers and
that's where you have all that some
[ __ ] live in a house where you could
watch the live stream that would be
interesting yeah it's a different it's a
different beast I think one another
aspect could be cool is if like they
could compete not only for like dates
with The Bachelor but also like they
could compete to like have like have the
option to take over the bachelor Twitter
account for a week or something you know
it means something superficial with
numbers attached to it so that you weed
out the people who are like I don't
really care for this guy but I'm trying
to get like my followers up like let me
get this let me win this challenge and
get this rose so I could take over the
two
account for a week or something like it
the more I think that would create
spoilers because it's recorded yep
well that's true but you could also not
find out who won until the seasons or
something you would just find out later
I don't know I just think that it would
be really cool because there's a lot of
like young good-looking successful
people on YouTube they're smart and nice
and I'm sure would love a situation like
that maybe you know far less laced-up is
like the traditional bachelor bachelor
that would never consider an online
personality yeah or they're too young or
whatever and I was like you know it'd be
great though like even not just this
like I'm seriously looking for love like
let's get those [ __ ] musically kids
up in here we've got like 16 year olds
and you're like here's a 16 year old
version of The Bachelorette and it's all
just like it's super like young
teenagers like that'd be fun obviously
there's no alcohol and like illegal
things going on but like I would love to
watch some young teenagers have cute
conversations and hold hands like that
is adorable shows like summer break
that's kind of like that right you were
rushing for legal reasons maybe they
would need to be a no you know what
summer break is it's about summer break
was like it was like I think I don't
know if it's still happening I think
AT&T was like the main sponsor was a
youtube series where it was like reality
TV for high schoolers basically and it
was that when they were on the summer
break and that's that was the premise
and you know my brother's friend was on
it and that's like how he got his like
Internet whatever his numbers is you
know start but like they do they've done
that before where they've documented a
reality show format on YouTube of
younger people or not creators or just
people that's cute but I wouldn't want
to even curate it I'd be like yo just
keep it real if you guys aren't
interested in each other just [ __ ]
you can leave yeah it's super reality TV
yeah for sure if the season turns into
five episodes of Jared and Alison
talking to each other on a couch I'm
like I'm kind of here for it that's
[ __ ] cute what are you guys fighting
about or we have a vine season where
every every episode is only six seconds
and they have to cram
but I feel like there's so many like
single people on YouTube where we're
like you know what we could even if you
don't find anybody that you actually
like like let's set this up and have it
be a [ __ ] thing could be cool it
could be cool it was really fun yeah
that's our best idea
the YouTube bash was our best idea right
it's a the executor nodding heads yeah
yeah for sure
but like oh the the joke last night was
that we were both gonna co-host it we
were gonna be Chris and Harrison I have
to speak in every other word ladies
welcome tonight rose ceremony is
happening the one that retweet okay you
not just survive you're not playing it's
The Hunger Games everyone wrong we're
cops I think it would be such good like
reality television on YouTube but we
don't have well cuz I I think like on
cable mm-hm
or like TV like live TV the last kind of
bit of show that I still watch them you
know watch SVU sure like I'll watch you
know [ __ ] like that survivor for sure
but the last dying kind of group that's
really really getting whittled down to a
small group of content I watch on TV is
really just like shitty reality TV and
that totally can exist online yeah
better like better content then is on TV
can't exist on and I think it's only a
matter of time before it does but I
think it's cool
to grab like this spin-off angle and
like make it more internet friendly
because I think it would improve so many
shows like should we move on to our next
is yeah give me a hypo I need okay yeah
YouTube dog best in show we take all the
YouTube pets and we compare how they
look and the winner is the best in show
so you have all the famous poppers the
dog owes weights are they being judged
like obviously like
have like a dog that doesn't necessarily
fit into a breed category so it's just a
good-looking respect okay so add can be
yeah yeah
but there is one sprint they're one of
the event is like so add might lose well
he might also die who is judging the
competition likes traditional dog show
people know so judging the competition
is Cesar Millan oh [ __ ]
controversial but okay wait he's
controversial I mean sometimes oh I
don't know that not too bad
okay Cesar Millan's cousin who's more
versed on the Internet okay his baby
cousin mhm what's his name salad Milan
okay and then we have what did I say
okay and then then on on the host on the
other gun saddle on him Cesar Millan's
baby cousin salad okay but salad Milan
is rigging the competition to put his
dog crouton in the show and win but it's
not fair no he cannot
and keeps throwing crouton in the arena
and we don't even know how he got there
get crouton up out of here
dammit get him out so it's just like a
yearly an annual dog show yeah okay yeah
not not salad Milan I think the best
judge slash caster for that would be
pansy okay she's commentating the
play-by-play of the dog pets so she's
giving us so cats like how you know
logistically do it if it's pets trillion
damages oh okay yeah the executives that
are watching yeah one of them just
whatsapp no we should we should do like
a straight up like just shallowest [ __ ]
who is the prettiest and now it
eliminates all the ugly ones so that's
what I'm saying who's judging it because
that's very important I know you propose
a change I
so if you if you took like traditional
Westminster Dog Show people and you're
like alright forget what you know about
like breed and stuff like that like
don't judge them based on their breed
judge them based on how sexy they are
okay and you got to declare a first
second and third okay every year okay
that works and who's the one like on the
floor running the show pansy
there we go so she's like she's
commentating live on the floor and all
every youtuber with their pet or their
dog has to be the one handling then like
walking them so we have to run at around
one leash just let go of the pet thing
it's just a dog show so just the dog
show just the dog should I give it that
okay just a dog show okay so that's
number two is complete number three and
guys remember that if you want to be
involved in the biggest story of 2018
which is going to be our YouTube read
series are multiple successful series
and then sold and pitched to YouTube red
you'll probably just read about it in
the skin because you're gonna wake up
you're gonna get the skin and you're
gonna say hey whoa two youtubers named
Jenna and Julianne launched up ten
YouTube red shows simultaneously and
produced and direct all of them and
they're getting six million dollars $600
okay guys if you want news waiting for
you in the morning and you don't want to
search for it and kind of trudging
through all the nonsense online you want
it just compacted in a nice easy to read
format the skin is for you and guys it's
free you literally just sign up for the
newsletter and it comes to your email
that's it if you don't like it you don't
like it but give it a try
it's really great okay you can learn
about the curler in the Olympics who's
been accused of doping curler oh my god
you can learn about all sorts of that
person have the dope for I don't know
you know I don't really know enough
about curling in the training involved
to even like speak on it it sounds
really silly and I get why everyone
laughing but who knows maybe their
training is like because I have seen an
improvement in the physique of curlers
over the years there are a lot more
physical looking than they used to be
seems like a bizarre sport to require
that type of performance enhancement I
agree I agree guys go to the skin that's
th es ki mm with two M's comm slash and
Julian sign yourself up for the email
and you will get the skin newsletter in
your inbox in the morning you can just
skip on over the water cooler just Karen
right in the right in the head with some
facts not on your fist just like you're
gonna learn her really really hard in
the face and that's it okay and right
now when you sign up you could be
entered to win a $250 Visa gift card
that you can spend on all sorts of like
pad thai if you're if you're down for
that because if I won that gift card I
would just spend it on pad thai also
guys if you love magazines but you don't
know how to like buy mag it's like
physical magazines go to magazines to
know what is it like mm like come on get
it on texture texture is an app that
helps you read all that all the great
magazines you want bone Appetit where
you can just like look at pictures of
food Sports Illustrated Men's Fitness
ladies and men you can get it right now
on texture comm slash Jenna Julian you
can start with a free trial it's an
awesome app and you can do it on your
tablet your phone your computer you get
all the magazines you want right at your
fingertips
and there's no wasted paper there's no
stacks piling up with what a stupid
thought let's make magazines so once you
read them it's just a thick pile of
papers that you have to just trash I
don't snapped right now try texture for
free by going to texture comm sauce
Jenna Jillian if you choose to continue
after your free trial you're gonna start
with $9.99 up sends a month which is
over a 30% discount like I said really
great deal check it out texture consult
Angela or link in the description thank
you sponsors thank you sponsors yeah you
can no no you can email us if you are
here from the sponsor we have a long
list
okay the next we have big brother but we
kind of already talked about that's
that's all Shane I really hope that he
makes that happen too but I would never
agree to do that
when did your feet cannot happen I don't
know but I like it feels good
can you turn a little more towards me so
I can put my feet on you more thank you
that's great oh oh oh okay the challenge
is our next wait we didn't talk about
big brother but so you that would be all
youtubers and they would have to live in
a house it's basically a big brother
right except instead of live streamed on
TV it's actually on YouTube we have a
question what what about big sister
brother
big sister brother big sister's brother
did you see James did a video mm-hmm did
you watch it
I watched the beginning of it haven't
had a chance to watch a whole I want to
beginning I watched like five minutes of
it today it was really funny yeah
brother sister brother sister give me
this
I made that sister anyways Julian I'm
listening they so in order to I think to
get youtubers to agree to that you'd
have to make it so they're totally
allowed to have their phones social
media they can focus in Big Brother
right now they can't have any of that
there's no accident no they're just live
and where are they live on TV how stupid
no on the internet well that's pretty
much the live streams on the Internet oh
but so I think you you can't allow them
you know different liberties than they
do on the show so they can they can work
they can tweet they can be on the in
Creek content they can vlog they can
edit but like they can also create their
own drama by doing that though - yeah
but like imagine just if you like Trisha
was on UK big brother but if that
imagine if she was on like you - big
brother
mm-hmm or we the name is up for news
well she's a lot like imagine the
problems that would arise where Trish's
like hey guys I'm gonna film in the
kitchen or I'm gonna go live in the
kitchen they're like Trisha don't go
live in the kitchen I'm in my underwear
cooking potatoes and she's like well
[ __ ] you I told you I was gonna go live
and then now we have problems every now
this is lit and let's think about this
[ __ ] that would go down it so you knew
like say
right now we knew that there was a group
of youtubers in the house hmm currently
hey do not break my sign brother
amazing I would tune in or listen or I
had scenario I was gonna tune in for the
tenancy either scenario so we knew it's
it's brother
we knew that youtubers were in the house
we knew his livestream we knew
everything was like like in the now
right now and all of a sudden someone
starts tweeting yeah got really cryptic
[ __ ] and we're like wait a minute
why are they tweeting this aren't thing
in the house yeah and then all of a
sudden you're like wait a minute are
they like are they serious yeah and then
just the drama is it's everywhere yes it
could be so plentiful yes there could be
fights yes there could be like all sorts
of there could be lawsuits which could
be fun ready for different you know no
one's gonna get any permission to film
anyone because by the time you're in the
show you've already signed away your
basically your waiver to be on camera on
everyone's vlog so now what you get film
doing you have already given the
permission to try to think of like who
would agree to that though like the
prize money needs to be a lot in order
to the prizes like subscribers given to
you but like you know for a lot for a
lot of people on YouTube it's like okay
well if I wanted to be live on camera
24/7 I'll just do it on my channel
that's true I don't really want there
have to be a big mess you need to give
me incentive to agree to that
100% there needs to be incident and also
say you have somebody on there who's
like whose job is X Y & Z you know and
you've never been exposed to them for
any extended amount of time like let's
let's say this is a terrible example
because we all know Liza ko she is
[ __ ] amazing and wonderful but say
like you only saw Isaac oh she's videos
and so you you know her is that then she
goes on Big Brother for youtubers and he
realized what she's like in person and
you're like whoa this is terrible not a
fan and like the Katy Perry livestreams
Oh such a trash when you all of a sudden
they're exposed to someone's like real
personality that's a huge risk that
they're taking by being on the show
saying like in order to get someone to
agrees with it it needs to be like
hundred percent so let's think about
what get me read a YouTube billboard
with your face on it from
awesome I promise to you liza coach he
is even more wonderful she's Swedish
terrible example but you don't him said
it was I agree with you that that was
about example she is very kind and sweet
and is nice in person yet you would
watch her on a live stream and only
liked her more unlike the Katy Perry
last rumor you like I hate you I didn't
feel any certain type of way and then
you went live for a week and now I
really don't like you know so anyway I
was gonna say something hold on the
winner by the way how do you win big
brother you just don't give her laugh so
the winner could have a cash prize Julie
Chen cash prize hold on cash prize say a
quarter million dollars yeah more than
that they get their face on a youtube
budget they get a face on like a
billboard a whole prize pull here our
whole budget is the cost of the house
and you guys can make the Billboard
they're saying yes to the Billboard
maybe it may be a fee for people to
agree to show up so they can miss out on
work and then have it be okay so so far
we have you get a prize cash prize if
you win you get two you also get like
resources to create content right like
they have editing setups they have
cameras you can use whatever like they
have a green screen you know I mean they
yeah they have like the prize money
needs to be the amount of money where
people will do anything like they'll
they'll do [ __ ] up [ __ ] well we could
get that number up I think I think we
could get one of them winked at me but
what does that mean no no we'll talk
about that after what do you think about
this idea okay they're being weird I
think one of the news likes me let's
just say 750 K oh ma
750k the people would be chomping at the
bit to get a spot in this house for
three-quarters of a million dollars he
gets everything the winner also gets
their face on a YouTube billboard for
like three months like their YouTube
featured creator across the globe
third they get Google preferred out they
get Google they get a hundred thousand
baht followers Oh giving them on behalf
of you to draw fake but there there
there's now so you get new fake
followers you get cash and you get
notoriety notoriety small where you get
put on a billboard it's more famous you
get to do maybe some of the lesser rated
late-night talk shows to talk about your
win oh my god yes like a like a mini
media tour like whoever will let you on
yeah basically the tour involves you
going across the United States and just
knocking on networks going on there's
podcasts hey Chi be on the show you go
on you got a youtuber podcast or podcast
or you get to have the winner of new Big
Brother it starts
they start at good mythical morning that
go over to the shane and a great show
that's what Alper - but it's the only
youtuber podcast and then over it I love
good mythical morning you come in here
yourself in this room I doesn't really
feel like enough of this self-loathing
iron ironically I think a youtuber
podcast tour would be cooler than a
late-night tour I can't stand sorry I
can't stand Jimmy Fallon a lot of the
late-night stuff I like Kimmel he's good
good stuff but for the most part I think
late-night TV is kind of just antiquated
and I think that can you just let me
talk for a second and I think that there
are podcasts or internet like sort of
equivalent to that are way cooler so
that's the ironic part of this but I do
think that's a funny idea the winner
gets to go on a youtuber podcast tour
across California not any other state
they only get to go in California so
they start with the best cuz nothing
good morning then they go to Shana
Branch tonight come to our dumpster room
and record a show with us and then they
come back to the Jenna Dewan podcast for
another episode except
yeah well that's I like that
I think the Big Brother idea kind of
that would be great evolved there but I
feel like also the there is no barrier
to entry like I think we can pick anyone
that identifies as a youtuber in hey so
there's no minimum sub-county minimum
sub count like yes so there's there's
people that have a lot to gain from just
that explains why when you were like how
we're gonna get people to if you offer
200k yeah a lot of smaller youtubers
would love this opportunity if you took
the majority of the budget for the whole
show and you made it the prize money now
we've created a situation where people
will do anything yeah they're already
signing their life away so you could
feasibly just like kill someone and it's
not even finished just saying I'm just
saying sorry you guys.i no legal is
crazy that's why I'm saying they'd
appreciate it
okay yeah I think either you be wildly
entertaining the whole thing is the
whole thing is sponsored by pajetta Troy
Bob no tax return you guys sponsor that
show can you sponsor a big brother no we
could get some kids gather some good
sponsors yeah I hope please don't bend
my knee backwards well alright well we
had the challenge yet so sort of the
same as like big brother really I'm like
sitting here like being a fool so if you
guys ever watched like the the challenge
on MTV where they basically take you
know the real world contestants are you
the one likes people from other reality
shows then they put them all in this
hyper-competitive like physical
environment where there's different
games so like vendetta's or battle of
the exes or you know they're all
different premises of how people get
eliminated and how they determine the
winner because they're all for the most
part a very physical show based on a lot
of politics and physical this it's like
it's a mix of like the real world in
Survivor so I would love to watch a
bunch of youtubers
because I feel like there's a lot of
people in the community that are like
unbelievable athletes and then you put
them together with people that are just
like like mastermind manipulators yeah
and just like regular people amazing for
it
also I'd like to just say that if you
were a challenge fan I am so into their
most recent season two days when it
brought the UK crowd over I think it's
it's like bringing the Jewish war crowd
into the challenge has been the best
move the challenges made in so many
years how much so here for it but um
so who would be the host who's the TJ
Lavin I know you're already hosting uh
oh okay you you host the challenge at
all host the bachelor bachelorette and
Big Brother so I have to host the
challenge yeah okay well I wanna do it
I'm gonna be on you want to be on it
yeah okay so let's think of a host hmm J
Cyrus oh yeah Jason
cuz someone would wipe out and he
wouldn't be able to stop laughing Jeff
would be a great host yeah you should be
like the number one else for all these
ideas I think yeah I mean now it's
pretty self-explanatory I'm hosting a
show about love would be fantastic they
can absolutely they can um stop it
serious they they can they can like be
on the Internet in the house there right
yeah yeah that's like the theme with all
these shows a spoiler because they need
more content by all means let go on
Twitter and go off and say whatever's on
your mind and then honestly when it airs
I'm gonna be dying to see what the [ __ ]
you were tweeting about so good for you
say whatever the [ __ ] you want all right
you pick out of those any others you
want to present we have one more well
the ultimate fighter oh yeah so because
everyone's now fighting each other in
boxing rings on the YouTube youtubes we
just create an ultimate fighter so we
put them all in a house they all have to
live with each other and talk to you
about each other and then they find each
other we great pretty simple pretty
straightforward yeah except it's MMA no
boxing yeah it's co-ed so I am
jacksFilms can fight each other
oh speaking of jacksFilms did you
the message about his dogs when it comes
to the best-in-show seriously yeah
they're invited because they're such
garbage plus they're gonna lose okay
that I like this one a lot the faceoff
for the beauty community so faceoff is a
show on sci-fi channel yeah and it's a
reality show with special effects make
makeup artists right doing challenges
different special things make up
challenges and they're incredible so
entertaining but like you wouldn't even
need that for you to know that's just
the format you just take all these
beautiful beautiful people and you're
just like okay you guys have five
minutes to create a look using these
print it's called Beauty burr it's
called YouTube off wow that's so clunky
I feel like I feel sweaty after you just
said that word I mean the ultimate
Beauty burr hub youtuber are you the
beauty burr B AB youtuber something with
Beauty Baretta will get the answer you
guys have some ideas alright they're
gonna they're gonna fax me some ideas
tomorrow beauty and the tease beauty and
the tea yeah cuz I'm here for the petty
drama okay so um you're allowed to
sabotage people too I feel like that's
fun so well how would how would it work
okay cuz they all have the same
challenges but aside from like actually
doing makeup and winning challenges and
having like the weakest player that week
voted off what's the social aspect no
it's talent based I mean they we can
have them all live in the same place I
think that's fun they can all use their
phones they can all do whatever like I'm
here for some of the arguments some of
the petty [ __ ] fine but like it is
talent base yeah its talent base but so
is so is [ __ ] Ultimate Fighter and I
love watching the my favorite parts of
Ultimate Fighter in the house yeah but
you said it's telling base I think it
should be tea based and then the talent
is just like a side thing no no many
people based on their work in face off
one of the things I hate is that you
don't even get to see him in the house
they like so I just said that you see
all of that stuff but it's like RuPaul's
Drag Race like I'm here for all you guys
arguing ever watch the show but
at the end of the day their base their
basing the who goes home based on all I
was talking about was this was the
division of content that's it like how
much content are we watching of them
compete and how much are we watching of
them in the house it's like a healthy
balance but it's a beauty competition
give me a percentage I don't have we
have the executives in the Rumania
percentage 50/50 good okay wow that was
exhausting you were tilted right now
well how did you just get so tilted but
I feel like those would be great chosen
if we had those it would be [ __ ] sick
all right well it's like like if you're
a young 20-something on YouTube and
someone was like look okay we're gonna
provide you with a not designer but like
a really nice wardrobe and hair and
makeup for like three weeks and we're
just gonna line up all these people for
you to for you to date and get to know
I'd be like hell yeah well yeah we got
this small fee we can pay you and you
get to live in a mansion and you can do
whatever you want
are you cool with that I'd be like hell
yeah and I also think something that
this this whole group of ideas have
going for it is that you can create
content while you're doing it it's like
I'm sure so many youtubers would want to
go on Survivor or want to go on the
child's but you know that you're gonna
take months off of your region change
could be the death of your channel give
you this this is a prime opportunity to
create some content that you could never
create a elsewhere well also we don't
own the content you're posting to your
YouTube channel yeah while you're doing
this that's enticing I think that's more
enticing than any other prizes involved
it's like you're getting the coolest
[ __ ] content if you're like at Andrea
Russett though or Trisha Paytas and and
you're like okay well we'll take care of
the wardrobe like pack nothing well
we'll give you like beautiful shoes
beautiful hair makeup whatever you want
like just let us know we'll make it all
happen for you and you just wake up
every day and look for love you know
what I'm saying okay like whatever you
want and you know what if your date at
the end of the days you want to go lay
on this couch and eat ice cream with
this guy like we're gonna take you there
and we're gonna record it as The
Bachelor ever has someone on The
Bachelor ever like one of the
contestants amongst the other women are
the amongst anime like brought someone
else onto the show like secretly snuck
another date
that's funny that's like that okay I
would love that show though
yeah I would love all these shows so
guys as you filter out just make sure
you high-five all the YouTube boos X I'm
a nice little pat and let them know to
fax us their thoughts tomorrow and we'll
see where it goes we have a lot of
offers on the table
yeah who's breathing down our neck
pretty loud and honestly tbh I'm ready
to give up the rest of my job in life
and whatever it just focus on this also
all my time is now devoted to all of
this this is what I do now
copyright this is all copy written now
can I declared it okay there's a seal no
one's allowed you can't take anything we
just said I just said you did we will
sue you for the cost of being frustrated
our lawsuit against you for stealing
these ideas will be free or $10 do not
promise I will kill you don't threaten
me I'm sorry YouTube executives she's
very she's hostile sometimes just ignore
there's dogs in the back go look at them
there's a hamster if we kill you you
won't know about it beforehand just know
that copy or after copyright thank you
and we did it goodbye forever
goodbye okay see you guys next week bye
let's call it YouTube blue why because
it's not YouTube red it's better Oh
YouTube Fire & Ice yes
[Music]
you
[Music]